[Musique]
michael est ce que vous connaissez votre
meilleur profil en meilleur profil
une silhouette estime équipe qui va vous
qui va nous aiguiller sur ça peut-être
ah oui tout à fait révolte frites je
vous propose de découvrir le métier donc
deux silhouettes east c'est pas facile à
dire une pratique très répandue à
l'époque de la cour au xviie siècle qui
a presque disparu avec l'arrivée de la
photographie inès ce temps cov ce cas
est venu et de versailles pour nous
présenter son métier
bonsoir ça alors pourquoi vous être
lancés dans cette aventure
alors c'est mon père et mon grand-père
qui sont donc silhouette east donc c'est
une tradition familiale et je pensais
pas que ça allait devenir mon métier je
les fais par passion
je les fais un parallèle de mes études
j'ai commencé à travailler un peu dans
l'événementiel et n'agit pas mal de
demander pas mal de succès j'ai commencé
à collaborer avec des avec des agences
événementielles et puis des maisons de
luxe françaises et puis voilà puis j'ai
commencé à faire mon petit mon petit
réseau et c'est comme ça que j'ai créé
la marque la silhouette east et j'essaye
du coup de montrer mon art de le revivre
un petit de le faire revenir en tout cas
je vous fais des silhouettes de plus
convaincants du coup cela doit faire une
dizaine d'années que je suis
professionnel parce que pour nous faire
une petite démonstration
bien sûr l'ancien les téléspectateurs ce
qui comprend vous avez marine et d'un
côté parce qu'elle a un bon profil oui
oui bien sûr est-ce que vous avez gardé
votre chapeau hommage plants vs
il faut combien de temps pour faire mal
ou de trois minutes de trois minutes 3
pour au final et et vous intervenez
auprès de particuliers vous exercez
votre à quel moment en fait c'est lors
de deux soirées événementielles donc par
exemple pour des marques de luxe pour
les lancements de produits d
inauguration de magasins je collabore
avec 6 aussi avec des avec des palaces
parisiens quand il donc il me propose en
fait à leurs invités
le sol de plusieurs personnalités
notamment
oui tout à fait oui paris oui par
exemple faudrait soit la forêt soit 1 k
jennifer lopez
là je me sens bien plus tôt je pense que
c'est mon instagram ce sera fumée
ça c'était pas tous en tête mais oui
quelques-uns mais qu'est ce qu'il put
difficile à faire dans une silhouette
il n'y a pas vraiment de difficultés
c'est vraiment je préfère les profils
avec la plus le caractère ça ressemble à
ça ressort plus plus facilement que je
conseillais quand c'est plus simple en
fait ce qu'il faut beaucoup
d'entraînement ont pas oui je pense que
l'on vous voit faire sa part et après
presque simple c'est parce que c'est un
âge 1,6 numérique aujourd'hui c'est pour
ça qu'elle convainc ciseaux pour
quelques coups de ciseaux c'est fait
voilà ce qu'il fait c'est presque
terminé on va pouvoir rien ne soit pas
trop anxieuse reste le résultat à l'air
d'être la voix qui aperçoit déjà il faut
savoir avoir beaucoup c'est beaucoup de
minutie
forcément oui ça c'est une des premières
choses d'avoir c'est l'observation et
ensuite et ensuite l'entraînement pour
pouvoir coordonner avec vous a fallu
quelques secondes pour effectivement
leurs raisons que ça
et voilà ça la caméra c'est encore mieux
voilà il a confirmé que notre action je
ne vois pas souvent de ce profil
l'ambiance négatif vous allez rester
encore avec nous encore un peu peut-être
pour vous livrer un autre exercice
et quel sera le cobaye le prochain dit
enjeux qui se lance mais honni 4 on sait
que ça va être compliqué quelle
silhouette si vous inspire le plus vous
voulez vous lancer
mais ce n'est pas michael ii 7 ans fasse
bon après ce sera compliqué ça sera pour
moi la mairie qu'elle est ce que vous
avez terminé bon train de retourner même
j'ai pas envie qu'elle faisait très bien
de ce côté le détail de la barbe c'est
plus que ressemblant et c'est très bien
réussi merci félicitations un instant g
d'armes au site internet pour trouver
les silhouettes isc la silhouette is sur
un programme la sécurité sur internet
est nombreux et nombreuses à faire à ce
métier n'est plus maintenant non plus
maintenant il y en a quelques-uns qui
sont plus de la génération de mon père
aujourd'hui est que ma soeur et moi et
voilà quelques-uns on est vraiment très
très peu ce sont plutôt les hommes
d'ailleurs qui j'allais si vous êtes à
l'époque exactement encore métier de
femme mais je trouvais que c'était un
petit challenge de donner un petit peu
de finesse et un peu d'amour à cette âme
vous avez déjà des demandes pour jusqu'à
noël animé la soirée d'un réveillon
oui oui j'en ai et là je suis en grosse
période
justement je fais pas mal d'événements
pour des maisons de luxe notamment la
branche de noël
oui je suis beaucoup beaucoup s'arrêtait
pas j'arrête paraît donc on peut en
vivre
vous arrivez à vivre cette profession on
peut on est vrai et vous cherchez à
donner peut-être des cours dans des
écoles alors que seul le métier se
conserve
est ce que dans un deuxième temps
j'aimerais bien transmettre oui bob
peut-être des élèves qui sont en école
d'art et à faire une date une formation
un peu restreint d'autant que peut-être
je sais pas une dizaine vingtaine
d'élèves mais oui ce sera avec plaisir
que je transmettrai pour ne pas perdre
les vieux les halles comme certains
disparaissent aujourd'hui les maquisards
dévolu si vous voulez pont des comédies
j'ai franchement je suis pas à ses
habits de fête avec des ciseaux
connaissez je suis très gauche et même
dangereux
à côté d'elle là c'est beaucoup merci à
vous
[Musique]